[Music]
let's go to patrick in cleveland ohio
what's up patrick
hey dr john good to hear from you again
you too man so okay so catch me up you
called uh i guess several months ago and
we talked about
some work struggles remind me of that
yes
yes sir we did we talked about how i was
battling you know being overwhelmed with
my career as well as trying to balance
the three bands i'm in oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay did you quit one of the bands
i haven't yet but i'm working on it what
a sucker dude
what a
you're one of those guys that calls for
wisdom you're like i'm not gonna do it
but that's cool no man i've taken
everything you said in the heart so
i know i've taken it into my heart i
haven't done any of it but that's cool
man um so
as a part of that call you mentioned
something about your girlfriend i said
hey man that's a whole other call call
back another time and then you did which
is awesome so tell me about what's going
on
and i can give you another
round of wisdom that you'll just put
into your heart and then go on about
your day
no i'm gonna do it man you're not doing
it you're not but go ahead
so basically my girlfriend and i have
been living together and dating for four
years now just north of four years and
she has every right and every reason to
want to take our relationship to the
next step i'm not denying that at all
and i give her every reason to but
you know i'm in this position where
i feel like everything going on in my
life and and my own mental instability i
feel like i'm just not ready for that
yet i feel like i'm not ready to marry
her i'm not sure if it's what i should
do if we're meant to be together if i'm
even fit for marriage at this point in
life or ever even then break up with her
and let her go man
but it's like
i then break up with her and let her go
yeah okay
it's like i don't want to do that i
worry that if i do that i'm going gonna
make a huge mistake because i'm not sure
if if i'm just self-sabotaging and i do
this in any relationship i'm in a
hundred percent yes
yes and yes and then yes on top of that
the reason i just told you to break up
with her so i wanted to see your
reaction
okay um i think you'd be making a huge
mistake quite honestly
i do
um
you're playing family now
right you're playing married now
um so what you're trying to do is have
both things at the same time kind of
similar to trying to have three bands at
the same time
and work a full-time job but also keep
this little
this little music thing you have a
grade a
like nat flashing neon sign
fear
of going all in on something
and if you want to do that to your
career and to your other fellow
musicians great don't do this to your
girlfriend
i agree you know what i mean
i do absolutely and here's why i'm
speaking directly to you like this
because i'm you
i'm you the number of times i've taken a
job and within six months i'm already
applying out just to see what's out
there i don't feel comfortable i think
something's gonna be mean to me what
it's just putting two feet in the
ground and i didn't realize that i was
dragging my wife through that and i was
i didn't realize that i was dragging my
kids through that and i was and they
deserve better than that i deserve
better than that and the people i work
for deserve better than that all that to
say is this your issue is not my issue
your issue's your issue
four years
is enough
make your decision and move on with your
life
it may be this
here's another thing uh i went skiing
this weekend with some friends
have you ever been skiing
water skiing no okay
um your water skiing behind the boat
um it kicks a big way wake up right so
it splashes a lot of water behind you
and it creates a wave that you've got to
get on one side or the other of it
and if you're skiing and you find
yourself and you it's and you find oh no
and you're split you've got one leg
outside the wake and one leg in it
it's super unstable
and at any second you feel like you're
going to face plant because you are
and usually you eventually face plant
unless you can get one way or the other
out of this thing you got to get back in
the wake or you got to get way outside
of it where the water's like glass okay
i wonder if a ton of your anxiousness
a ton of your feeling in ins like you're
you're feeling like you're uh have this
just profound instability
some of your mental health struggles if
you will
are because you ride the fence on
everything you're riding the wake on
everything
make a commitment man let me put it this
way what you're doing isn't working
try something else
try it for six months you can't try
marriage for six months but
um
try
quitting the bands
try what it's like to go all in on a
band
or two
tryouts like to go all in on your career
try what it's like to go all in on your
wife just commit i'm in she's it
this is it
why won't you do that why won't you give
yourself that peace being inside the
wake or outside man you're just riding
the worst part of this thing
it's like it's it's so hard to describe
but
um you know growing up and i did touch
on this in the last time we talked but i
had extremely unstable and unhealthy
upbringing my mom painted the worst
picture about women to me okay she
poisoned my head about women they're
this they're that they're gonna ruin
your dreams they're gonna ruin your life
don't let this happen you know she was
the mother of five boys with five boys
and it's just like she painted the worst
picture of women i've had tons of
girlfriends tons of intimate
relationships
and i almost feel more comfortable like
being with multiple different women and
starting something new and riding that
honeymoon high
then i do like being involved with one
person i feel more comfort in that
patrick but look at your life
i know i know it's a disaster chaos it's
chaos yes and so you can't tell
you can say that it's um
less scary initially
but it's killing you
it is and i don't want to be this way i
want to want to marry her i don't want
to lose her like i want to be in a
position where i want to run down that
aisle and and
here's how you get there patrick here's
how you get there choose to run down the
aisle there is no magical moment
there's not this moment you're going to
be walking through a grocery store and
all of a sudden the lights are gonna
shine on her in the right way
you decide
i'm gonna run down this aisle
i am gonna go all in you've seen people
on stage who are timid players and they
they make for a terrible um
they make for a terrible show
because they won't commit to the music
and then having fun while they're up
there
is that fair
no absolutely yeah
you're waiting for something that will
never ever come and you're dragging
another poor woman through it don't do
that i know i don't want to i think she
deserves so much better i don't
need that don't reassurance
i know it's like i don't i don't i don't
ugh
i don't want to pee on the floor i just
don't want to then don't go in the
bathroom
it's like that yeah i know
um
so i want to ask you something recently
you know her and i have been seeing a
premarital therapist i wanted to get
some external insight on our
relationship and it was almost like
you know i wanted to hear what she would
say about about us or you know should
you be together or not
i had a couple one-on-one sessions with
this with this therapist and uh
she diagnosed me with borderline
personality disorder now i don't know if
that's really a big deal or not but it
certainly does make a lot of sense
borderline personality disorder is one
of the most challenging
um
mental health disorders
very very hard
very very hard
i believe that i have that okay
definitely lines yeah
so you have to make a choice
of a life of volatile
explosions
and a trail of people who loved you and
who are also hurt because you melt them
or a choice
of
in this professional relationships
personal relationships or
you are going to put in
hard work over the next three to five
years
um
of dbt and rebt like there is treatment
protocols for borderline personality
disorder it is very very challenging
you're gonna have to decide i'm gonna
pull the string on like you just
mentioned these emotional highs
and i'm going to learn to
um become one with my body and one with
my emotions and learn what these signals
mean versus what i feel like they mean
and you have to put that work in
what i'll tell you is there's healing on
the other side of that it's hard but
there's healing on the other side of it
and if i've also seen people who don't
deal with it and it is
a trail of pain
that's your choice man yeah
i certainly am ready for the roller
coaster i can't live like this and i
know that i'll end up just
hitting the wall you know at some point
in life i'm proud i am now i'm proud of
you for that
thank you
um did your clinician offer you any
well let me say this number one
borderline personality disorder is
over diagnosed with regularity okay
so i would go sit down with a
licensed psychologist in your area
and let them know
that i've been diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder by a premarital
counselor
um
a licensed a licensed
you know clinical uh therapist too and
opc is fine
but i've been diagnosed
i'd like a full um diagnostic test on
this
and then i want some treatment options
moving forward and there should be a
good practitioner in your area
okay okay
um if you decide i'm gonna get very
serious about healing
know you're in for one
hell of a ride it's hard okay
because you're having to relearn how you
experience the world people with
borderline personality sort of
experience separation as a flamethrower
they experience love and joy as a
carnival
and so it's it's learning to accept
these different versions of how your
body feels you have to relearn how to do
it and it's hard
uh but it's also incredible
okay okay
yes that can uh that can certainly
explain why i pretty much always self
sabotage things and
does do those just that that is that
example of a carnival versus a
flamethrower does that make sense
oh yeah okay all right
um so
so
be about healing man
be about healing
um what's your girlfriend say about
being married to you
she wants nothing more than that it's
like
she understands this prognosis i'm
dealing with she wants to ride the ride
with me i guess i feel i feel guilt
almost like let her be an adult let her
be an adult i know she's a grown woman
let her be an adult
if she says i'm in it then you've won
the lottery my friend and she's in it
and then you have to look at her and say
i'll be in it too
now i did ask her one other thing i
wanted to ask her that
you know
what if
we just aren't meant to be together
and you're i don't buy them for this
there's no such thing as that
okay you all can choose to not be
together you can choose to not be with
her
but the meant to be together thing is is
hollywood fairy tale bull crap
okay i believe you okay that makes that
makes sense you've been with her for
four years you'll live together you know
you know the ups and the downs and the
sideways
okay
she's flying like a kite out there in
the wind
and she said she is um
willing to
ride the ride with you but she wants
some security and i once she wants to be
on the roller coaster with you but she
wants a seat belt
and she wants to know you're going to
stay on the roller coaster you're not
going to jump off
and that's super super fair
yeah absolutely or you can say i'm not
interested in riding
which that's fair for you too
it's the ride in both sides of the wake
man that you gotta you gotta quit
yeah is that fair
it is fair yeah
all right you're a brave guy you're a
brave guy what i would tell you is now
it's time for action if i'm you or if
you're my son or you're my brother or
you're a friend of mine
i would tell you go get a true
um
go get a true workup
okay if i truly have i want to know if
i've got a borderline personality
disorder diagnostic
not and again i'm not trying to
you know spit on your on your marriage
therapist but i want to go get somebody
who is proficient and skilled in that
and in the assessment and i'll see if
that's a true diagnosis
and if it is
awesome that's fully you and there's
some extraordinary gifts that people
with borderline personality disorder
have
some incredible gifts how they see and
experience the world they're a blessing
and there's some intense healing that
has to happen too is that fair
yeah okay go be about it
go be about it man
and my hope is
um
my hope is the next time you call which
you will you're gonna call me back in a
few months
you're three months five months six
months into healing
and you're calling to tell me hey we
broke up for good i made the choice she
made the choice we broke up for good or
we're engaged
um not because we weren't waiting on
some some
you know hawk to land on the telephone
pole to be like you're supposed to be
together or some vampire to come you all
just made adult choices we're in we are
all in and we're gonna ride this thing
together we're gonna do it
and know this
got borderline personality disorder
healing is hard
it's hard and it takes a long time
and it's worth it because i've seen the
other side of it it's beautiful it's
incredible